There are retirees in Austria and other European
countries and other countries around the world
who have received U.S. corona virus stimulus
checks for twelve hundred dollars or direct
deposits, many of whom have not lived in the
United States for decades, many of whom do
not qualify for such stimulus payments. Only
U.S. citizens and U.S. resident aliens are
actually eligible for the stimulus money that
starts at twelve hundred dollars and phases
out up to ninety nine thousand dollars in
income. And we have all sorts of examples
of this from around the world. There is a
24 year old citizen of the Dominican Republic
who last summer worked in Cape Cod and got
a twelve hundred dollar stimulus check signed
by Donald Trump. There's a 73 year old man
from Linz, Austria, beautiful place, who worked
as a waiter in the United States for two years
in the 1960s, who received and was able to
cash a stimulus check. His wife, who never
worked or lived in the United States, received
a twelve hundred dollar stimulus check. O
r f reports that banks in Austria can confirm
that they have cashed dozens of checks for
residents of Austria. And it is unclear how
many of them received checks without actually
qualifying for them, without actually being
entitled to them. There are thousands of foreign
workers who entered the United States on temporary
work visas who received 12 hundred dollar
checks in error. During that first round of
stimulus payments. And of course, that money
is mostly being spent in their home countries.
Our domestic corona virus stimulus is partially
going to foreign countries, which I'm not
opposed to in principle. But that was not
the point of the plan. One hundred and twenty
nine countries have received at least one
mistake in stimulus check. This includes Brazil,
Canada, China, India, Nigeria, South Korea.
And there are a bunch of different comments
about this that we could make. So let's start
sort of at the lowest logistical level. Government
officials and tax experts say that the reason
for these mistakes include that many foreign
workers file tax returns incorrectly in the
United States. So if you're a foreign worker,
there is a particular way that you were supposed
to file your taxes. Often those foreign workers
mis file their taxes as if they were U.S.
residents, when in fact, they are merely temporary
workers. That could be what led to them receiving
a check when they weren't supposed to receive
a check.
Now, there's a higher level discussion to
be had here, and it does actually sort of
like to two different discussions. One is
we have such a convoluted system in the United
States from the standpoint of taxation and
filing taxes that it is almost inevitable
that this sort of stuff would happen. And
I know that it might be fun to say, oh, this
is Trump's fault. It's really not Trump's
fault. What is Trump's fault is the failed
response. The fact that he promised a second
stimulus, we still don't have it. The fact
that we've had six months of pandemic and
just one twelve hundred dollar stimulus check,
that's all that's Trump's fault. But a lot
of this is just our systems. Now, some on
the right will say, wow, David, you sound
like you want to simplify the tax code with
something like a straight up flat tax. No,
no, no. That's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is that the systems, including
the fact that you have companies like Intuit
and these companies that make Turbo Turbo
Tax and other tax software constantly lobbying
to keep the tax code more complicated. That's
a piece of this. That's a piece of this. We
could have a simpler system without going
to a system that is unfair, like a flat tax.
And then lastly, there is this sort of big
picture, aggregate economic element to this,
which is that of the one point four billion
in stimulus checks that, for example, went
to dead Americans, 30 percent of that money
is still unrecovered as of the latest report.
So if you believe in fiscal responsibility
and fiscal conservatism for lack of a better
term, this has also been a major, major failure.
Meanwhile, there are some foreigners who do
live in the United States and who are married
to U.S. citizens who have not received stimulus
checks, though by every sensible approximation,
they should be entitled to one. And then again,
more importantly, where's the second stimulus?
We are now six months into this Congress.
I think maybe is just back or about to be
back from vacation. No second stimulus. We've
got an election coming up. We've still got
a raging pandemic. What is going on with that?
And that is that continues to be an unanswered
question. But at every level, there are aspects
of this that have been completely mishandled.
Not all of them are Donald Trump's fault directly.
But certainly the situation has not been improved
by Donald Trump and Stephen Manoogian and
others being at the helm and money just flying
around the world. Some I know in the audience
will say, hey, that's that's maybe a good
thing. And sure, I mean, listen. We're supporting
different people like I guess. But at if we're
not even properly supporting Americans, I
think there's a very reasonable case to be
made that money shouldn't go to Austria to
people who aren't actually entitled to the
stimulus money. Let me know what you think.
Let me know what you make of it.
Yesterday, The David Pakman Show had our best
single day ever for audio podcast downloads.
I know I've said this like eight or 10 times
in the last few months. It's because the podcast
is growing dramatically. Consider yourself
invited if you normally watch on YouTube.
One clip at a time, but you'd like to have
the full hour show all at once. Get the show
on iTunes. Get the show on Spotify. Get the
show on Pandora.
Stitcher, whichever is your favorite podcasting
app. Let me know where you are in terms of
a second stimulus by letting me know your
thoughts on Twitter, where you can find me
at David Pakman.